[Musique]
et 12h30 c'est l'heure de quitter
l'édifice on se trouve à l'assemblée
nationale pour aller par le tunnel à
l'édifice pamphile le may où a eu lieu
la conférence de presse du premier
ministre tous les jours à 13
[Musique]
c'est devenu un rituel presque sacré au
québec depuis le début de cette crise
le point de presse quotidien de françois
legault et de ses acolytes est une
source majeure d'information pour les
journalistes
et pour le grand public qui suit tout ça
en direct et c'est ce qu'on doit
comprendre qu en ce moment et comme une
espèce de chicanes de docteur de savoir
que deux millions de personnes qui
suivent la conférence de presse c'est
sûr qu'avant de poser une question va y
penser deux ou trois fois pour être sûr
de poser la question la plus claire
possible la plus pertinente la plus
précise alors comment ça c'est qu'on est
en difficulté à faire atterrir tous ces
gens là qui veulent aider notre collègue
hugo lavallée est un habitué de la
nouvelle le mess politique quotidienne
il constate que la population est avide
d'information sur la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire
c'est absolument incroyable en douze ans
de journalisme j'ai jamais reçu autant
de messages sont sur toutes les
plateformes facebook instagram twitter
par courriel et c'est stimulant dans la
mesure où on sent que le travail qu'on
fait véritablement l'impact que ça
touche les gens
au cours des dernières semaines les
salles de nouvelles se sont
progressivement vidé pour faire place au
télétravail des journalistes c'est le
cas pour une bonne partie des collègues
du centre de l'information à radio
canada mais pas pour tous
je vais travailler sur
les renforts qu'on attend dans les
établissements et je commence avec une
entrevue écoute on retourne quand même
dans nos familles le soir dans faut
prendre nos précautions donc au
caméraman est assis donc en avant place
du conducteur moi je suis en arrière en
diagonale le pot vraiment s'assurer
qu'on respecte un tant soit peu le deux
mètres de distance
c'est important quand même de montrer ce
qui se passe à l'extérieur et de
l'illustré et de demeurer cette fenêtre
là pour les téléspectateurs je trouve
que c'est excessivement important encore
plus aujourd'hui de faire le maximum de
terrain de garder notre capacité de
production que nos équipes de
journalistes réalisateurs et cameramen
puisse continuer à faire du terrain le
télétravail est maintenant généralisé au
journal le devoir à montréal la salle de
rédaction a été complètement déserté ce
qui n'empêche pas nécessairement les
journalistes de se rendre sur le terrain
l'équipe de travail de la maison on
essaie de privilégier les entrevues ou
téléphone par courriel
mais on le dit aux gens que faire du
terrain était encore possible
on s'est dit collectivement que notre
place était pas dans les couloirs d'un
hôpital en ce moment mais on apprécie
ces situations locaux parcours
c'est un moment vraiment fascinant pour
quelqu'un qui est un beat santé c'est
une situation sans précédent qu'on verra
peut-être plus jamais donc oui un stress
mais en même temps c'est un peu
privilégié de voir un peu comment notre
société réussi à attaquer ce problème là
notre collègue spécialisée dans la santé
enchaîne les rencontres avec le
personnel soignant et les familles de
patients depuis des semaines il y à une
profusion de sujets à traiter les gens
éprouvent grand besoin de parler d'abord
vous avez défini ce que ses forces aient
forcé depuis un mois beaucoup de gens
qui nous appellent qui nous approchent
pour nous donner de l'information pour
nous transmettre aussi pour nous parler
de leur état d'esprit de leurs
inquiétudes leurs angoisses
quand un médecin te parle de ses
craintes disons que c'est assez étonnant
et ça parle beaucoup je pense de la bhl
de l'ampleur de la crise que vit
actuellement
c'est important aussi de voir ce qu'est
un décalage entre les messages
communiqués par le gouvernement par
exemple ça va bien aller
tout va bien avec par exemple la réalité
du terrain
on le devient des témoins il faut
conserver ce rôle là faut valoriser
seront là parce qu'il est il est crucial
en ce moment et puis je pense que c'est
sur le terrain qu'il manque là que la
nouvelle loi
[Musique]
en italie le pays d'europe le plus
durement frappé par la pandémie
le confinement générale et prolongée
jusqu'en mai le rôle des journalistes
est devenu crucial comme l'expliquent 7
vidéaste romaine qui a pu pénétrer dans
les unités de soins intensifs qu'ovide
de deux hôpitaux
évidemment c'est plus inquiétant
d'entrer dans un hôpital et dans une
unité de soins intensifs qu'ovide que de
rester chez soi j'ai fait des terrains
de guerre avant j'allais dire que c'est
à peu près la même chose tu peux pas
dire que les images on tourne soi à soi
réjouit sortent elles sont extrêmement
triste en va des gens qui sont intubés
qui ont des casques tout le monde a vu
ces images mais je pense aussi que ça
permet aux gens de comprendre combien
cette maladie combien ce virus peut être
grave qu'elle quelles conséquences ça
peut avoir sur les personnes et
peut-être que quelque part ça encourage
aussi les gens à rester chez eux
on l'appelle la zone rouge passer cette
porte tout est considérée contaminés on
essaie de démêler le vrai du faux et je
dis beaucoup beaucoup dans les équipes
ce qui est fondamental en ce moment les
faits les faits les faits notre rôle
aussi c'est pas juste de faire la
nouvelle de suivre l'agenda
institutionnel de rapporter les
nouvelles qui devraient être apportées
qui sont dramatiques parfois comme on le
voit dans les chu celle dans ce moment
mais c'est aussi d'accompagner les
lecteurs de leur donner des outils des
clés
devant le désarroi mondialisée les
médias d'information sont devenus un
service public essentiel
donc on n'est pas des héros on n'est pas
des préposés à l'intérieur des
établissements où il ya vraiment de la
contamination
mais c'est sûr qu'on est peut-être un
peu plus exposé que la moyenne des gens
donc on essaie de faire attention tout
en jouant justement à notre notre rôle
d' comme les autres les entreprises de
presse sont fragilisés par cette crise
les chutes de revenus publicitaires en
traîne mises à pied et baisses de
salaires paradoxalement les médias
d'information sont plus populaires que
jamais